what's going on guys
Jurassic world roared into theaters
indominus rex massive box office but is
it scientifically accurate don't ask me
I just stand here and talk in front of a
wall of toys you know who does no
scientists join me as we explore the
movie science of Jurassic world
oh and hey one person who hasn't seen
Jurassic world spoilers ahead we're
talking movie science today Jurassic
world and we're lucky to have our old
friend dr. Clifford V Johnson welcome
back doctor always good to be here
you saw Jurassic world what'd you think
of the film overall speaking as a
physicist mm-hmm not a biologist did you
take any electives that dealt with this
type of stuff
sure okay great you're an expert it was
a fun monster fight but it could have
been so much more so I was a little
disappointed as a layman I thought it
was an action-packed thrill ride I'm
very happy to be joined by Trevor Valley
and sir you are a paleontologist yes
what exactly is a paleontologist a
paleontologist is the you know we're
people that study ancient life so
dinosaurs Ice Age mammals tiny little
trilobite that are half a billion years
old fun stuff like that we're not
Indiana Jones anything Knight because
we're not archaeologists paleontologists
we don't dig people so you're a loner
yep as a scientist how do you feel about
the movies depiction of science in
general kind of poor because I think
it's really focusing too much on just
the bad monster that came from the
science that monster goes off the chain
indominus rex was effing s up yeah but
it was just killing yeah what'd you
think the film overall oh you really
want to do that
okay um indominus rex crap crap just
stick to the science there's so many
other really cool dinosaurs out there
that they just could have had a field
day with they made something that's more
badass than any other dinosaur you want
to do something badass put feathers on
them how far away is science from
frankensteining a creature like we saw
in the movie well if you want to be
really strict I would say infinitely
our way in other words it can't be done
if you allow them some leeway here and
there a very long time the only thing we
can do right now is take the living
descendants of dinosaurs birds and kind
of tweak them other colleagues have
taken birds and kind of like turned a
gene on and off and widen the beak or
they've how do you turn a gene on and
off that's like I mean you say it like
oh yes do this it's literally just
adding an enzyme that triggers the gene
Wow but since we have no DNA the whole
bug in amber thing crap
the Mosasaurus in the film the that
giant fish light creature it jumped way
out of the water a creature that large
is that possible for to jump that far
out of the water I thought about that
and wondered just how deep that pool was
that it was in yeah because uh it would
have to maybe get a real head of steam
going in order to come out at that speed
to get to that height probably the real
question is how deep is the pool I don't
know they didn't say what about that
that megasaurus is that it was that a
real thing megasaurus the the oh sorry
what about the Mosasaurus the Mosasaurus
was cool it was way too big but you've
got the argument of hey they can make it
as big as they want because they're
genetically modifying it blah blah blah
okay I'm actually I have something that
can tear that entire thing apart I just
thought of it what so they're using the
whole bug in amber thing right yeah
Mosasaurus lived under the water how did
a mosquito get its blood it jumped out
of the water the mosquito landed on it
BAM Oh can't go with that but okay oh no
that's what happened one of the cool
thing is if you look really close when
it opens its mouth it had teeth on its
palate on the upper palate of its mouth
that is factual that is that's hard
paleontological science right there all
right so you know you're you're citing a
lot of things that are fairly accurate
well yeah like five okay sorry
how close are we to the government
actually militarizing raptors well I
would say we're very far given that we
don't have raptors yet we don't have
Raptors so completely implausibly far if
you were dr. Wu how would you feel if
your
creation led to the deaths of dozens of
people I'd be devastated if I created
some horrible thing and then it goes out
and is horrible yeah I'd be upset but
would you still do it maybe one or two
more times depending on box office I'm
not motivated by ticket sales in the
work I do so that would not change it
for me which dinosaurs actually did have
feathers your avian dinosaurs ended up
being Birds
those were your t-rex is your Raptors
your over Raptors Utahraptor Deinonychus
and all that what about the Toronto
Raptors they should have feathers on
that on that too scientifically wouldn't
it have made more sense for Bryce Dallas
Howard to take off her high heels while
she's running through a muddy jungle yes
that I can say with 100% scientific
Authority would have been the smart
thing to do to be fair when you're
running an absolute panic you don't
really think about something as simple
as I'm going to take off my shoes maybe
there was never an opportunity to get
alternative Footwear and maybe heels
would've been better than nothing at all
I don't know it's a wild guess according
to fossil records could a t-rex and a
Velociraptor team up to fight a
genetically modified super dinosaur
leading to a grudging respect between
the t-rex and the Raptor again from a
scientific perspective no the transverse
Rex was from the Midwest like Montana
velociraptors were from Mongolia but
let's just say that they happen to find
themselves on the same street at an
amusement park if they won that fight at
the end would they give each other like
a little nod did the concept of thanking
exist amongst dinosaurs probably not
let's boil it down
I want to hear scientifically your
favorite thing and scientifically the
thing that most made you cringe I'm
gonna straight onto the cringe
maybe I'll get back to this rate
favorite thing oh okay we're told that
the creature the monster forgettable
downfall indominus rex has had no show
social contact with any other animals
and is just you know confused out there
what have you yeah and then later in the
movie at another crucial point it runs
into
the Raptors showing remarkable social
skills and convinces them to give up
years of training and attack the humans
being a human being I can go to a random
other part of the planet and have a
devil of a time telling them I'm hungry
just the fact that we share the same DNA
does not mean I can suddenly have a
conversation with them well look at this
look what am I saying
are you feeling sick show me on this
doll where the movie offended you in the
heart right there I love you Trevor
that's great yeah Trevor
mmm-hmm why are you saying I'm not real
because you're not I'm part cuddle fish
not cuddle fit to wanna cuddle no are
you having fun playing with me Trevor
now if I could like you know get one of
the hulkbusters off the wall and just
did you just pitch a marvel Jurassic
mashup that would be rad that would be
rad I would be down with that guys
summer 2018 get ready I'd be totally
done with that oh hell yes right ah
once again I've been proven to be a
Jurassic sighs so what'd you think of
the movie was it a fun ride or was it
too flawed for your discerning palate
let us know in the comments section
below best answer we are going to send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank our scientists Trevor Valley and
dr. Clifford V Johnson thanks for
watching I'm Howard Nick hit me up on
Twitter I might behold a nude Chris
Pratt plucking away at his guitar on the
Fox teen drama The OC
all the Bears died